when do you think it's appropriate to
start splitting the bill on dates I am
more than happy to go dutch I believe in
equality for all so I I like the ying
and the yang the yankei pan sometimes
I'll pay sometimes it kind of sets the
tone for a relationship and you know I
got your back you got my back having
said that if it is the first date
he better offer to pay or there will not
be a second base
[Music]
well I will say I love it as a gesture I
think it's really sweet and I appreciate
it but a lot of times I feel like no I
want to go dutch on the first date
because we're both feeling each other
out and I don't want someone to assume
something so I I like one definitely
okay well
I mean
I feel like it just depends on the
delivery right yes like if the check
comes and he looks over at me like yeah
[Music]
yeah then so you need to you need to go
ahead and put down on this and I'm gonna
go
um not never to be seen again but I
think I think that needs to be discussed
early on right like how how much of a
date is this are we still are you
interested in courting me for real or
did you did you ask me out or did I ask
you out or was this like a setup by
friends I feel like those things need to
be discussed early on communication will
eliminate any room for everyone
have we done this poor of a job with our
young men yeah
yeah have we have we not talked our
younger men
but this is really supposed to be about
I'm sorry the way it is supposed to work
and I can appreciate everything you all
are saying because you're women so quite
naturally you set the tone for how you
are
but let me say this to men
it's the proper thing to do it's the
right thing to do and it's the way it
should be done
you got a lot of nerve you know dudes
kill me because we got a lot of nerve
thinking this thing is 50 50. because I
got news for you it ain't they happen to
have a skill set that you'll never
possess they can produce another human
life
that's nothing you can do can come close
to that I'm ashamed of men who don't
understand them in addition to that part
of the conversation it needs to be made
clear to men that women don't owe you
when you take us to dinner
just because you buy me dinner just
because you paid the valet doesn't mean
I need to go home with you absolutely so
that in that same conversation that
still needs to be said and I think
that's why so many women still want to
pay because you don't want to be bought
right because you don't want the
perception of the obligation exactly
because now I am not for sale correct
yeah because nowadays A lot of times in
the situation the women might be making
more money then he need to play in the
playground he qualified to play
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you are born to be a provider you were
born to put a woman on a pedestal and
treat her like a queen that's your job
as a man now if you don't want the job
go do something else it's an honor to
take a woman out hey that is true
this pissed me off right here
I'm just sick I'm a matter of fact
ladies I'm sorry I'm sorry
look at all these men I've been looking
at this man right here with the lady
next and lady in the teal is that your
husband
this dude been getting he been going
yeah the whole time that dude up there
with the lady with the with the sad show
he was going yeah cause he that man with
the blue t-shirt on with the lady with
the green t-shirt I've been looking at
all these men going yeah cause we know
that's how this work y'all getting
tricked man these young dudes out of
here man if you don't understand that
and don't email the show tomorrow see
you got money Steve ain't always had
money
I had nothing I have never ever in my
life
from every date I've ever went on and
Adam been on some dates
had a woman pay for nothing for me
different time different times this was
when I was good in Pope if I didn't had
the money I saved it so I could take out
yeah I'm sorry man all right we gotta
take a break we got more straight talk
when we come oh my God can there be two
king of Sims I think Derek's been
dethroned oh my God that was awful
why tell me why that was too much man
first of all how old is he I don't know
40s no no oh my God
he's on the way it's a different
freaking time it's like
how can you say that oh yeah you know I
didn't have a job before I was broke oh
yeah every single day I paid it was
probably it was much more less than it
is now there's just so many things to
consider and he's not even yeah that was
yeah that was again offensive yeah and
like they didn't I mean as Michael was
saying earlier like I don't think the
women then were sleeping with the other
guy yeah that was like true courtship
yeah beating to a serious relationship
marriage commitment all that good stuff
yeah all of the guys and couples that he
pointed to you in the audience looked
old
I don't see anyone that looks like since
they looked like they look weak you know
their wives brought them to that oh
absolutely and he knows he has to clap
Bradford yeah bro you're using old
people as a measuring stick for the
current Society it doesn't correlate so
it doesn't it doesn't work bro and like
again he's saying oh don't email because
you're saying I've got money but you do
have money though we talking about bro
in the UK the the energy prices have
gone up considerably house prices have
gone up considerably it's not easy bro
do you know what I'm saying like I
really can't stand these people that act
like everybody's balling we're not all
living some uh rock star life it's
unrealistic bars yeah and like at the
end of the day he's talking about oh
yeah this is an honor what do you mean
bro the woman is a stranger bro and and
with that all that advice yeah oh yeah
you need to pay on a first date make
sure the date is cheap bro every guy
watching this year let me tell you keep
the check the date cheap then it ain't
gonna it ain't gonna hurt you bro
maximum 50 pound maximum Max I agree
because if I like a guy I don't give a
[ __ ] where he takes me yeah if you if
you really like it like if you're really
into a guy you don't give a [ __ ] he
could take you to freaking make that if
you really like him like you might you
might you know wish it wasn't McDonald's
but you're still just happy to be there
yeah you're happy to be there yeah
inside you're gonna be like oh I wish
you took me to a little restaurant but
you're not gonna care bro I'm telling
you on one hand the amount of girls that
I've taken out on a date like a proper
date like one hand bro and those girls
were already my girlfriend bruv
so I've already found out or or like the
realization has come that she actually
likes me and she's invested in one way
maybe not monetary but she's invested
she's invested time energy there's no
one word answer replies like she's
actually showing enthusiasm to get to
know me and that and show me that she
likes me bro that's somebody yeah okay
boom I can take you out but not for some
stranger bro and all of that is a lie
bro and they're trying to turn the
majority of men into Sims they're trying
to feminize uh men mention that have a
backbone we shouldn't have an idea or a
perspective on anything this is whatever
the woman wants it goes bro you got
stupid idiots like Steve Harvey 99 of
his audience are women all clapping old
old women clapping yeah like what are
you talking about bro it's propaganda
it's nonsense bro you know what I'm
saying so at the end of the day he's
just the same he's just trying to make
money I understand get your bag but bro
anybody with half a brain will
understand that this is this is BS bro
do you think women owe men sex
if he's taken her out of multiple nice
dates
I wouldn't say oh that's that's a strong
word oh that's like deserve see what I'm
saying no one deserves anything and I
don't think a woman owes a man sex but
at the same time bro like everything is
an exchange in this world bro like if
you're if you're if you're dating a guy
you know the guy wants to sleep with you
I don't care how nice he is to you I
don't care how he how he talks to you
you know he wants to sleep with you bro
so if you're dating a guy and you know
you don't want to sleep with him you
shouldn't be dating him RAV
that's it
I mean other people might not agree with
that but why why would you be seeing a
guy that you have no intention of
sleeping with them eventually so what
you're just going to be dating and
dating him dating him he's going to be
wasting my time and money for what for a
girl that's not interested this is what
I'm saying this is why I can count on
one hand the amount of girls that have
actually gone out there and spent proper
money on a date for those girls were
already my guilt
and guys need to understand because
guess what that girl that you're
spending 200 300 pound on on a
restaurant at hakasano Gaucho yeah that
girl is sleeping with a guy for free
hundred percent the outside so it's all
right I'm not trying to hear any of that
bro serious and I've been that guy to
sleep with girls for free many times bro
you know what I'm saying Jim dates bear
gym dates come on man
gem dates yeah gym dates
get me what is it a gym day okay boom
let's say yeah yeah workout together
okay okay let's work out together or um
what's it even even simple let's go to
the the uh shopping center just walk
around they worked out with you and they
wanted to hook up after sweating yeah
like obviously I'm wearing the vest and
that
he's like yelling at them and stuff no
I'm not actually training them I'm not
training them they're like we're going
there together like you know what I'm
saying yeah I'm gonna go there anyway
it's real like that and again it's just
like what you said if the girl if the
girl likes you it doesn't matter where
you go bro yeah I agree so true that's
so true take me to Popeyes and talk to
me that's all I want I want chick
sandwich and everything one more time
exactly more time you eat one sandwich
have one drink the drink will you you
drink half the drink you'll be there for
like two hours just talking because you
actually like the guy you're interested
in the guy when these girls talk about a
guy has to pay this and he has to take
me here that's for the guys they don't
really like they use it that's what it
is yeah I don't I don't think it's
always like
conscious you know like but I do think
like a lot of times like women were so
indecisive that it's like like I don't
know sometimes guys get taken advantage
of you know
you're saying guys get taking advantage
of because what women are indecisive
um
like personally I don't have a ton of
free time so like I wouldn't I think my
time's valuable so if I don't like a guy
I'm not gonna go on a date with him but
I think a lot of guys like wait for
years in the friend zone and I think as
women like we kind of know this
and sometimes like it
a lot easier in the friend zone for a
reason yeah because you know you don't
like him so he's not indecisive you just
don't like him he's just there yeah
that's true he's doing it to himself
really yeah that's true what do you
think of guys that stay in the friend
zone idiots
the girl but more time the guy knows but
he's just I don't know he's been
watching Aladdin or Sleeping Beauty or
something bro I don't know bro you've
been listening to Derek Jackson or Steve
Harvey I don't know what it is but you
need to understand if the girl sending
you one word answers if she's taking 24
hours to reply to her message she don't
like you she's piping letting somebody
else Piper bro that's it move on find a
girl that that does like you and the
uncomfortable truth is for a lot of guys
is that more time like this is not my
honest opinion more time the girls that
you like don't like you that's
uncomfortable but that's just the
reality because just like what you
always say on the dating apps what women
swipe right how many times
um women's right break between five and
like 15 of the time where men swipe
right 50 percent roughly there you go
there you go yeah so that's the reason
that's the reason like women hate men
and like they say things like men are
trash and like men are the problem and
even like men need to rise up it's
usually because they're sleeping out of
their league because it's like a girl
that's a five six maybe seven sleeping
with an eight nine or ten and then
they'll say oh like men don't do enough
but no it's because you're picking the
guy that's out of your league and you're
getting plan C attention because that's
where you're at oh and another thing
what Steve Steve saw the simpy said yeah
is that oh well if you're trying to date
a woman that's out of your league then
playing your own playground well guess
what the women in that guy's playground
probably still want to date a guy that's
higher than him anyway so it still
doesn't equate and that's that's the
thing like those women like how many are
120. that are that are in that income
bracket
I don't know they might be I don't know
but it's like he's equating the same
like like that men and women have the
same type of Standards when they don't
and they obviously don't yeah and so
it's like just because a girl's
successful
if she if she only goes for guys that
are above her she'll probably be lonely
yeah
he wasn't even he wasn't even
differentiating women he just said women
you know right like he didn't say
successful with me he says oh well maybe
she's at your league what are you
talking about a lot of generalization
yeah man even in the wedding day they
say it's a it's a bride's day like the
guy really likes that my guy just turns
off and and he probably paid for
everything the napkins the napkin
holders and whatever she's like bride's
day and even they say happy wife happy
life oh yeah and I see that in the store
you know that's what they filled their
house with and stuff like she's always
right like why do we have terms like
that
so and it's like haha as soon as the guy
you know I don't know there's like
merchandise for the guy it's just like
it's just wrong as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible